en esta región el gobierno interino de
afganistán ha anunciado ayer ha sido
recibido por un sector con escepticismo
y otro ha dado la bienvenida entre ellos
para que estaban el gran aliado de los
talibanes y también lo ha hecho china
que ha dado la bienvenida a que se
finalizarán estas tres semanas de
anarquía en afganistán y asia que ahora
hora de empezar a reconstruir el país
qatar que ha sido el gran aliado de los
talibanes en estos últimos años ahí
estuvo su oficina política allí se
llevaron a cabo esas negociaciones con
eeuu también ha dicho que es el momento
de darle la oportunidad a que ellos
muestren su pragmatismo con las acciones
sin embargo hay otros más escépticos
como turquía al presidente erdogán ha
dicho al tayib erdogán ha dicho que está
a la espera de va a ver cuánto durará
este gobierno interino y que está viendo
cuáles son los desarrollos que hay en
afganistán y lo mismo ha dicho irán de
cierta manera que siempre ha apoyado un
gobierno inclusivo donde estén las
diferentes etnias en el país es siempre
lo ha dicho el presidente iraní y
también lo decía ayer el ministro de
relaciones exteriores que
coincidencialmente a esa obra nombraba
el gobierno hablaba con el ex presidente
hamid karzai si retiraba y reiteraba que
se inclusión de diferentes etnias era la
única manera para que hubiera paz en
afganistán llama la atención también en
muchos sectores especialmente en los
medios de la región lannoy la
eliminación de ese ministerio a las
mujeres que existía hasta hace tres
semanas nadie pensaba que hubiera una
mujer en ese gabinete sin embargo sigue
resonando la prensa hoy esas protestas
de las mujeres en diferentes ciudades
del país protestando por esa exclusión y
pidiendo por sus derechos